la chanson maintenant avec nina hagen in
again on l'avait vu l'année dernière à
paris c'était au casino de paris nina
guen était venu déjà chanté et elle
revient à châteauroux précisément c'est
de m'asseoir à châteauroux nina hagen
qui sera donc la vedette de ce festival
qui aura duré toute la deuxième
quinzaine du mois d'août à châteauroux
un festival d'ailleurs je profite pour
le dire qui accueille aussi mory kante
gérard blanchard jean guidoni enfin
toutes sortes de craie l'enchanteur
bonjour nina hagen
ça va bien
voilà je souhaitais j'étais sûr vous
parlez pas mal français
ouais une petit peu bateau
libanais ce fut en fait je pars un tout
petit peu français mais je préfère ma
bateau le sol et j'ai écrit mes mémoires
oui oui vous écrivez vos mémoires mais
en quelle langue
enders m d'abord en allemand oui voilà
fait ce livre là c'est ça le livre de
nina hagen qui s'appelle ich bin ein
berliner
voilà alors justement c'est le titre
aussi d'une chanson de vous chanter
il ya un truc tellement qu'ils oublient
c'est une chanson de manquer les manques
qui savaient dès l'hiver et moi je dis
moi je suis berlinoise et vous allez la
chanter à châteauroux où la oui bien sûr
bah écoutez on va aller chanter beaucoup
de nouvelles chansons on va tout de
suite l'écouté cette chanson
ok
marie
nina hagen sur ce plateau merci d'être
avec nous ni nagan je trouve que vous
avez c'est vrai que pour beaucoup de
gens le disent vous avez changé vous
êtes très calme très tranquille vous
êtes habillé assez sobrement et
j'ai l'impression que vous êtes moins
passionné qu'avant pour les provocations
pas je viens de faire une tournée aux
états unis et meehan
disent que je suis beaucoup meilleure
qu'auparavant
peut-être que cette impression de calme
que vous avez c'est dû au fait que je
suis très concentré que je travaille sur
mon nouveau disque
qui est enregistrée en union soviétique
et
matériels de châteauroux et de
l'union soviétique sera utilisé pour
faire un 33 tours
direct oui mais c'est vrai j'ai
l'impression que vous avez quand même
choisi plus la chanson que la
provocation maintenant moi je veux pas
vous provoquer
mais non je ne pense pas du tout parce
que sur scène la provocation
se fait par le biais de chansons où les
jets de l'afrique du sud et il est tout
à fait clair que l'allemagne et dirty
les salles la provocation fait partie du
show maintenant moins de bruit
oui oui
beaucoup de gens disent que je chaville
provocative mais je ne fais que dire la
vérité oui
oui par exemple lorsque je parle des
déversements chimiques dans l'océan de
l'apartheid en afrique du sud même
lorsque je parle des objets volants non
identifiés c'est vrai ce sont des objets
que j'ai vu et surtout pour les ovnis
parce que ça c'est de la preuve d'une
certaine manière une provocation sinon
les autres sujets il ya beaucoup
d'autres chanteurs ou comédiens ou
hommes politiques qui militent contre
oui c'est vrai je pense que nous formons
une grande famille et il faut avoir
l'esprit de lutte pour changer
réellement le monde dans lequel nous
vivons un monde qui est réellement très
dangereux et très provocatrice
personnellement je ne pense pas que je
sois provocative mais c'est le monde qui
est provocatrice alors vous disiez que
vous intéressait aussi à la politique
vous avez assisté un journal télévisé là
on a parlé de la pologne au début je
vous vous êtes une femme qui vient des
pays de l'est vous pensez que c'est
vraiment en train de changer
oui je pense qu'effectivement
une certaine visualisation positive
peuvent changer le monde j'ai écrit tout
cela dans mon livre j'ai formé un parti
politique qui s'appelle le groupe des
féministes extrémistes et nous sommes en
fait une organisation soeur des nations
unies et nous luttons sur le front
féminin oui ça veut dire que vous pensez
que ça peut changer mais est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est déjà en train de
changer à l'est
oui certaines choses changent déjà plus
il y a deux femmes dans les
gouvernements
plutôt eu la paix règnera sur la planète
plus il faut avoir plus de femmes dans
les gouvernements merci nina hagen voyez
comme vous êtes que vous êtes
transformés vous parler politique c'est
formidable merci beaucoup au revoir
vous voyez tout dans mon livre ben voilà
nina hagen donc fin de cette édition du
journal le prochain rendez vous de
l'information ce sera bien sûr le
journal de 20h présenté par henri
sannier tout à l'heure puis tout de
suite vous avez rendez vous pour une
météo complète avec laurent cabrol
excellente après-midi sur antenne 2